all right let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
historic moment this weekend the spacex
dragon capsule made a water landing as
the two astronauts
returned from the international space
station after two months orbiting the
earth
this was probably this was this was not
probably this was the first splashdown
by
american astronauts in 45 years i
believe so you can check it out here you
see the footage
um that's got to be disconcerting
i mean you know among other things i
just
i i cause i think i get freaked out by
landings
just on a you know a delta flight from
chicago to baltimore
uh that whole experience freaks me out
being on a plane i i'm high anxiety on
planes
and everywhere else in life to be honest
but especially landing
um so just imagine descending 250 miles
from orbit
and landing in the ocean with in a big
capsule with parachutes attached
here's um astronaut doug hurley
expressing his thanks to the team
um and getting understandably emotional
after after landing safely safely listen
to this
go for spacex here we have our first
view
of i just would like to sort of
reiterate what bob said
and add my thanks to
everybody over the last several years
that's either worked in hawthorne
mcgregor or down at the kennedy space
center
anybody who's touched endeavor uh you
should
take a moment to just cherish this day
especially given all the things that
have happened this year
we certainly can't thank you enough our
families can't thank you enough
just proud to be a small part of this
whole effort to get
the company people
to and from the space station they can
celebrate with each other
cease and desist
thanks so much doug and you're welcome
and thank you so much for those kind
words
and we all wish you a safe journey home
and a happy reunion with your family
soon and we look forward to seeing you
in person as well
gotta think about the relief he must
feel in getting out into the open air
again
he was cooped up with other astronauts
for two months now granted the iss is
pretty big it's like
equivalent to a five or six bedroom
house but even so
two months unable to leave unable unable
to go for a walk even
except a spacewalk has to be uh
a challenge another interesting fact
about the iss that i just learned and
i'll i'll mention it because i looked it
up on google so i was curious
um i knew it traveled fast around the
earth i didn't realize that it goes 17
000 miles an hour orbiting the earth
orbiting the entire earth every 90
minutes
so i'm guessing that's something you'd
probably try not to think about when
you're
strapped up to a tether and walking
around the outside of that thing
but i don't know great story there
number two not so great story the boston
marathon bomber
dzhokhar tsarnaev who murdered three
people and wounded hundreds of others
just had his death sentence thrown out
by a federal appeals court
now to go back to the lower courts and
this thing will drag on even longer
uh the reason for throwing it out as
reported by the ap is that supposedly
quote the judge oversaw the case did not
adequately screen jurors for potential
biases
and you know
this is why so this guy's been he
committed his crime seven years ago
just throughout the death penalty
sentence this is why the way we handle
the death penalty in modern america is
absurd
you know this guy there's no question
that he's guilty he's confessed to it
there's no doubt about the guilt in a
case like that
mass killer high profile
act of terrorism no question about guilt
been convicted
um he should be taken out back and
dispatched 30 minutes after the trial
concludes
what do we need all the appeals for
do not pass go do not collect 200 do not
sit idly in a jail cell for 7 years or
27 years
just take them right to the gallows take
care of it with a rope or a firing squad
cheap easy done and that's justice
and it would also be a good thing for
any potential future murdering scumbags
to know
that the moment they're convicted
they're dead
this isn't going to be 20 years of
appeals the moment you hear that
we find the defendant guilty and then
the sentencing happens
you're done for it um kiss your mama
goodbye because
that's it maybe they say that one of the
people who oppose the death penalty will
often
argue that there's no deterrent factor
with the death penalty
i don't know if that's true or not i'm
not sure how you could even
say one way or another because it
requires you to
look into the minds of of killers and
and
determine whether they were deterred or
not i i don't know if you can
really determine that but if there
is little deterring effect to the death
penalty now
maybe there'd be a lot more of a
deterring effect if it happened
immediately after sentencing and that
way it becomes more real
to the potential murdering scumbag
just a thought three speaking of federal
courts making terrible decisions you may
recall the supreme court last month
announcing that a huge swath
of oklahoma is actually somehow an
indian reservation
what that means is that the state of
oklahoma can no longer prosecute
crimes committed on this quote-unquote
reservation
all of that now goes to the feds which
means that a whole slew of violent
criminals
will now get to walk free as the feds
sort through the mounds of paperwork and
figure out what to do with all these new
cases
the new york times reports uh one
example of this one of many
a woman named kelsey lip was sitting in
jail charged with robbing and
killing a man in fact she here's what
she did she allegedly did
she lured a 25 year old man named dustin
barham
into her apartment allegedly at which
point
he was robbed shot and and then bled to
death
now she gets to go free for the time
being
because her public defender uh was able
to
to produce her tribal identification
card
so because her distant ancestors
lived in an indian tribe that means that
she gets to
for now get away with allegedly robbing
and shooting and killing a man
um and this isn't this is not an
isolated case many violent criminals who
are awaiting trial or or who have
already been convicted
now stand to be released while the feds
figure out how to handle this deluge
of new cases but but this also can
happen
um not just if the suspected criminal
was a tribal member but even if the
victim was a travel mentor
here's a another case from the article
it says dustin dennis who prosecutors
said was not a tribal member
was charged with second-degree murder in
july after his young son and daughter
tegan age 4 and ryan iii
were found dead in his sweltering pickup
the children climbed into the car were
apparently overcome by the heat
while mr dennis slept according to
prosecutors um tulsa county prosecutors
had to drop the case when it turned out
that the children were cherokee on their
mother's side
mr dennis was charged federally with
child neglect but
the tulsa district attorney said it had
been devastating to tell the children's
mother he was dropping the case
so um that might be a surprising aspect
of this for people
was for me as well that it's not just if
the criminal but even if
a if a victim a child
is a tribal member then that means that
their killer gets to
at least for the time being walk free
number four lena dunham um my my
personal favorite actress
posted on instagram revealing that uh
she had coveted a few months ago
and she wanted to tell her story and the
reason to tell her story was to slap
some sense into the quote careless
people
who do reckless and dangerous things
like jog without face masks
that's what she's worried about because
yeah imagine that very reckless
you got to make sure you wear that face
mask while you jog because uh
you know you you wouldn't want to
contract coven 19 while you're running
down the street
i mean there hasn't been any confirmed
cases of that at all
happening but still it could happen so
make sure you wear that face mask don't
be reckless
but then lena starts dramatically um
recounting
her tale of sickness and this is this is
what she says let me pull it up
i got sick with covet 19 in mid-march it
started with achy joints which i was
unable to distinguish from my usual
diagnosis so i didn't freak out but the
pain was soon joined by an impossible
crushing fatigue
then a fever of 102 suddenly my body
simply revolted
the nerves in my feet burned and muscles
wouldn't seem to do their job
my hands were numb i couldn't tolerate
loud noises i couldn't sleep but i
couldn't wake up i lost my sense of
taste and smell
a hacking cough like a metronome kept
timing kept
keeping time inability to breathe after
simple tasks like getting a glass of
water
random red rashes a pounding headache
right between my eyes
it felt like i was a complex machine
that had been unplugged and then had my
wires rerouted into the wrong inputs
this was on for this went on for 21 days
days that blended into each other like a
rave gone wrong
i was lucky enough to have a doctor who
could offer me regular guidance on how
to care for myself
and i never had to be hospitalized this
kind of hands-on attention is a
privilege that is far too unusual in our
broken healthcare system
i self-isolated with my pulse oximeter
uh
monitoring my levels after a month i
tested negative for covenanting
was able to spend time around my
isolation pot again
i couldn't believe how intense the
loneliness had been in addition to the
illness
okay and she goes on from there
describing it but
i have to say yeah it sounds like she
was she was sick
uh very sick and i'm glad she recovered
but
most of what she recounted there in in
dramatic terms
with creative analogies and metaphors
and all of that
also describes my experience with the
flu which i had back in february
um i was very sick for several days had
a fever considerably higher than 102
actually
and um and and i did have to go i was in
hospital i
wasn't admitted but i did have to go to
the hospital for and then i had symptoms
that
wiped me out i was exhausted for like a
month after
that um even after the fever went away i
it dragged on for weeks after that i
felt i just felt kind of wiped out
and not myself my point is not that
covet is the flu my point is that
with kovid people especially famous
people celebrities
will tend to recount their experience
with covet in this over the top
dramatic way expressly to scare you
i mean she admits that that's what she's
trying to do she wants to scare you into
wearing a mask while you jog so there's
an agenda behind this
um and it's it's it's just it's
dishonest
i'm not it's not this i'm not saying
that she doesn't she didn't have covet i
believe she had coveted
i don't think she's she's lying about
that but the story she's really telling
her
is a story of being pretty sick not
deathly sick
but pretty sick 102 okay for a little
while
and then getting better okay that's what
actually happened
when you boil this down to the basics it
didn't hap doesn't happen that away for
everybody there are people who have
there there are many people who have
died from it there are people who get a
lot more sick than that there are people
that get hospitalized
but the story she's telling she was she
was pretty darn sick
for a little while then she got better
so why not say that
i mean why the effort to turn this into
a cinematic fight for your life
well again we know why she's clear about
why there's an agenda behind it she
and she wants to scare you into behaving
the way that she thinks you should
behave
so we should just keep that in mind when
we read these sorts of things finally i
want to show you this
this was posted by speaking of dramatic
um the sun a uk newspaper
posts some truly shocking footage i mean
this is mind-bending
mind-blowing mind-boggling okay
all of that you're not gonna believe
this
this again was posted by a news outlet
just to be clear
and they wanted to demonstrate how hot
it's been in the uk apparently they're
in the middle of a little
heat wave and so they wanted to show how
hot it's been
and this is the video that this news
outlet posted watch
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
wow amazing
it it it's so hot
that it melts ice cream if you keep the
ice cream in the sun
for 20 minutes my god
i have never seen anything like that
before i
have have you ever seen that i have
never seen ice cream i've never heard of
that
i've never heard of that happening i
didn't know that
you're telling me that if you bring an
ice cream cone out into the
heat in the summer in july
august now you're telling me it will
melt melt
really
just absolutely
amazing truly global warming is going to
kill us all
and our ice cream even worse so that's
that's pretty big news just wanted to
share that with you
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content